Dr Liam Fox of the MP for North Somerset
and a supporter of Rishi sunak he's with
us good morning to you good morning
lovely to have you with you we'll talk a
little bit about heat later because I
think you've got some advice for us um
but first I mean what did you think of
last night's debate how did your man
Rishi do I thought he did extremely well
I thought he was Head and Shoulders
above the other candidates in that
debate and the reason I say that is that
because we're electing a prime minister
this is not a leader of the opposition
this is someone who will have to be the
prime minister in about seven weeks time
and I thought he had a better grasp of
the detail I thought he was very clear
in what he was saying he was relaxed and
and he was confident and I thought he
just looked like someone who who could
be the Prime Minister I mean most people
say he probably was the best performer
but do you find the sort of the sniping
that's going on uncomfortable to watch
well you know when you have a contest
with the leader of a party you have to
expect that it's a genuine contest and
it's nice but it's very personal isn't
it you can see there are some points
there which game personally Liz and
Richie couldn't barely look at each
other the last night there are but um
when you're an elected politician and
you're comparing it to the House of
Commons last night was quite team
compared to what we used to and I think
that's our position you guys are on the
same team well and and of course
um what I think was good about the
debate last night was that when we come
together after the contest you can see
the the very rich reservoir of talent
that we have to choose from I mean we
should see like perhaps came across in
uh out on top in a number of opinion
polls but it doesn't seem to be doing
that well with the conservative party
members who of course he'll have to do
well with who's going to win why is that
well he's won both ballots so far which
I would say was pretty good and MPS and
in a Big Field a big field and we'll see
amongst the members when the members get
to choose the members don't know who the
two candidates are yet going to be but I
think that what was very interesting
about the debate
um was was one point that Rishi sunak
said which was if the conservative party
is not the party of sound money then
what is it about and I think that lies
in a lot of this debate now the one
thing that's very clear is is that all
the candidates want to cut tax that's
what conservatives want to do the
question is when is the appropriate time
to do that and I think that when you see
that Russia's plan has been endorsed by
three previous conservative chancellors
you have to earn tax cuts the economy
has to be in good shape to do that
otherwise you're simply borrowing more
money and that falls onto the Next
Generation and I don't think that's
either economically sensible nor morally
acceptable and he made the point firstly
and you make it there but that doesn't
seem to be coming through with
conservative members because if you look
at the head-to-heads Rishi versus anyone
he actually uh apart from against Tom
tuganda and penny more than by just he's
actually behind on the other two with
well when you're talking about
conservative memories you're actually
talking about the readers of the
conservative home right so that's not
the same as conservative members
representation of the way that the
Grassroots feel well when I spoke to my
members at the weekend and I had my
constituency executive that wasn't
um how they felt and they felt that uh
uh she said had been performing the best
um of the candidates it's not surprising
he's been the chancellor he's across all
the detail of government as you would
expect a good Chancellor to be and I
think that comes across yeah and we've
seen that he's put out a new uh ad for
himself just uh before the debate I
think we can have a take a little look
at it now as well uh this is uh laying
out credentials as a brexiter he
campaigned relentlessly during the
referendum where others argued for
remain
oh others argued for remaining a picture
there of Liz trust that's not very nice
politics is it well I think the key
thing about him and brexit is that he
was a young MP I know that he had a lot
of pressure put on by the David Cameron
team when you're a young MP and the
Prime Minister phones up and says don't
do this but won't be good for your
career
um there's a strong temptation to follow
that line but he didn't he said I
believe in brexit it's something that
drives me politically and I'm going to
campaign for It Whatever the cost to me
in terms of early political career I
think that says a lot about someone and
frankly I think that's what leadership
is all about I mean how do you think he
dealt with some of the personal attacks
that have come at him over the past
couple of days I think last night he did
pause and try and talk about historian's
family store and he he told a story
about his father-in-law
I think was great to hear someone
um talking that way about someone who's
come with almost no money built up a
great fortune and that is what our
country's wealth is is based upon and I
think that defense of the creation of
wealth is really important because
um we need to build up more wealth in
this country if we don't build up wealth
how do we fund our public services so I
think it was great to hear that it was
great in a sense in the sort of academic
sense of making the point of why
conservatives believe in wealth creation
but I think it was also a very human
story that a lot of people can relate to
about people who come to this country
and they work hard they build up and
they do well and you know that that's
the great thing about our country and
Rishi of course is looking forward to
the final debates to be held on Tuesday
if he makes it through
I'm pretty sure you'll make it through
um and you know he's he's a consummate
debater he's extremely good at the
dispatch box in the House of Commons
he's very common very fluent very
confident I think that came across and
as I said that he strikes me as every
inch someone who's ready to be the prime
minister in just a few weeks time okay
adult Fox to appreciate your time this
morning thank you very much for being
with us